yeah welcome to a new video playing
Grand Master oh my god forget his name
I'm sorry Rodrigo Vasquez Schroeder from
Chile he's very strong very strong blitz
player okay so we got a mainline room i
play my trusted Chi Goren which is it's
not the greatest line I mean especially
the line that I'm playing but it's um
one thing I know I played this so often
and I know now I'm how to play this and
at least I'm I know you know some some
quick moves that I kept it always always
real out okay yeah well whites whites
main idea is a piece sec on g5 and on f5
g5 nonsense on f5 night f5 this is what
white often wants to do I'm trying to to
get a bit of play here to keep him
keeping busy so what what are my ideas i
can try sometimes to exchange this
bishop so you know maybe here attacking
be three this is just for for irritation
so
I'd like to play Bishop to h6 okay now
they can go Bishop to be to it I don't
mind that so that i get Bishop h6 in
this is not not too great okay it's the
diagonal towards my king but but still
it doesn't look like em there should be
something happening soon okay so maybe I
can get rid yeah Bishop f4 is the symbol
hmm don't know I can take it this this
actually would open up the diagonal yeah
g5g five four sir very passive north
hmm yeah there's a before it's not good
okay this is ugly I admit it but g5
assembles that is so annoying I must
stop it okay
so take him and put put a night on g5
yeah this second this kind of this line
here it's not really active or great or
whatever but it is very resilient you
don't get get pushed over quickly this
is what is this much is clear okay King
them wants to shuffle
like to get rid of this h4 night but
seems difficult to do I actually have an
idea with this even if you probably
don't believe me see 80-76 as the idea
okay I'm also checking see form yeah
night a four is just funny looking but
it doesn't doesn't do much
yeah let's take it and now is seven the
ice a ticking of 6cm I wanted to go
nitey seven but it's not possible
Knight f6 I want to go night g6 now is
who's playing so quickly I don't know
how they help people do that I mean so
yeah I mean thoughts on or are also bad
what is playing but probably have time
wiser when did it will who be enough it
is just playing too quickly why not yeah
well maybe it is still so good I don't
know but he didn't see any of this we
just let it happen it's probably still
good for white this is Sir this is the
the the bad thing I take me six years
Queen d5 and the store is some is very
annoying cannot take be three
can I can move the rook rook to e7 maybe
we'll go to be 70 this is actually an
idea taking with the rook on a six if
you take sale yeah this is the cipher
namely viable at least down from
proposition point of view the time is
the problem not the position is got a
dead bishop and the six point is the
gaana with increment I would win this
game probably but not with 12 seconds
check
check yeah okay there was a fluke age
seven but it's a couldn't win in 10
seconds the position was of course
completely winning for black black yeah
i was i was worst first and then then he
just played too quickly and support this
this is this is just just excellent I
can take p3 even but I have 20 seconds
on the clock this is winning but it just
takes it just takes takes longer ok YUM
and now instead of taking rook h6 is
just waiting for black and some material
is equal but he's got a dead bishop on
on f1 and I have simply having a tech
here Luke h6 Queen g5 taking 13 for
whatever its they're just good for lag
but ok now he's playing playing all
these moves very quickly and I had some
trouble with defending especially I
spent a ridiculous amount of time here
and this is this is some okay you need
to do this it's still ok for black
probably but still still very resilient
but i was playing playing too slowly
alright thanks for watching